I think we're gonna go ahead and get
started thank you everybody for coming a
quick show of hands this is your first
time to book culture on Columbus ah
well welcome to the family 20 years ago
this space was the Endicott bookseller
and it was lost to the Upper West Side
along with many other wonderful
bookstores over the years but of almost
two years ago we took the plunge and
opened our third location here and we're
so happy to be a space that's able to
host Jules Farber and this wonderful
panel to talk about James Baldwin in the
new book James Baldwin escaped from
America exile monks we have plenty of
copies up front so we do encourage you
to pick up a copy or two or three some
way we could stay in this neighborhood
as a community space so first let me
introduce our panelists
Caryl Weinstein is the mother of Danny
or a mother of Daniel Baldwin also on
the panel and was a partner of James
Baldwin's brother David whom she met in
1964 later Jimmy would refer to her as
his sister out of LA and when Jimmy
Brooke bought the house in st. Paul
Devon thank you David and Carol first
visited Jimmy there together in 1977
from Amsterdam where they were living at
the time they drove there to celebrate
his buying the house Carroll also
visited in 1974 and then again several
summers from 1975 into the 80s with
Daniel she and Daniel also made a
nostalgic visit several years later
after Jimmy died and Daniel visited his
father David there as well when he
became very ill
Carroll was a very active participant in
the afternoon sessions at the Welcome
Table we're all aware the author sought
criticisms of this work and completed
completed in the early hours
Daniel fondly recalls his Uncle Jimmy
walking hand-in-hand with them up to the
town center visiting many villages in
the area and sometimes carrying him
being taken on sightseeing tours to the
coaches or to Paris to swimming in the
columnar pool mornings and to the
oceanarium in the monte carlo along with
being taught just and the sandy and
astounded at finding Baldwin's books and
many strange languages for him in the
house Carol is a longtime Upper West
Sider and a longtime patron of book
culture and hails from Brooklyn New York
and has managed to travel and work
extensively across the globe during her
lengthy career currently is chief
learner of her sole consultancy learning
works she provides consulting services
in diversity inclusion and human
resources learning and development and
leadership management across any
workplace she's also associate professor
for graduate programs and her proudest
accomplishment is her son Daniel and his
and his greatest accomplishment her two
grandchildren Populi nough and graham
isaac daniel the nephew James and son of
David and Carol father of Graham and
poppy his husband of China is a
professional audio engineering
consultant and sometimes visual artist
who resides in Providence Rhode Island
from traveling with his mom since he was
born in New York City and having lived
in a few other places he has had the
benefit of seeing much of the world
though now he enjoys a much quieter
smaller life in Providence New England
okay
thank you thank you also joining us is
British born Nicholas Delbanco who lived
near Baldwin in Provence for a number of
years he was a regular literary sparring
partner and in his book running in place
scenes from the South of France he
comments on the frequency of time spent
take talking at Jimmy's table
Dabangg Co has published some 29 books
of fiction and nonfiction his most
recent novel is the years his latest
nonfiction is the art of youth crane
Carrington Gershwin and the nature of
fine arts Delbanco was the director of
the MFA program and and the hopwood
awards program at the University of
Michigan until retirement 2015 and he is
the Robert Frost distinguished
University professor of English language
and literature at the University of
Michigan but now lives just around the
block from our store on 114th so all
these New Yorkers together come together
as a result of their association with
this project done by jules Farber who
attended Rutgers University in New
Brunswick where he received a Bachelor
of literary letters in journalism while
residing in Amsterdam the Netherlands he
wrote for various American and foreign
publications and was awarded the
prestigious William the silent prize by
the Minister of Foreign Affairs for the
best articles published in the American
press about the Netherlands
Barbra wrote and published in English
and Dutch editions for four books and
since moving to Berlin's
he's written three more books all
published in French and English and but
his most recent project has been this
collection again James Baldwin escaped
from America exile and promotes so again
thank you a quick round of applause for
our panelists if rituals
I'm gonna go ahead and turn it over to
them oh you're right one last note
unfortunately George Wein was not able
to join us tonight for the panel he was
very disappointed but he was not feeling
up to it
he turns 91 on Monday and he had a flu
shot early this week and had a bad
reaction to it so he stayed home but he
wanted us to know how disappointed he
was and that he really loved Jimmy
Baldwin and was really looking forward
to reminiscing with the others about him
again thank you Jules
can everybody hear me all the way the
first thing people ask me when they hear
about the book is why did you do this
book about Baldwin there been enough
books and literary commentary and so
forth and I did it because of an
accidental finding discovery of a
photograph of James or Jimmy as they
called them at the hotel in sample the
vaults and luck along door the famous
hotel many of you probably know it and
the whole Hollywood crowd goes there
during the can at Film Festival and
years earlier Picasso and Chagall and
everybody came there and they sort of
traded artwork for meals and the inside
of the hotel restaurant was full of this
wonderful things I thought it was fat
because I loved James Baldwin's work
from the time I was in high school and
bred many of his books I thought it'd be
interesting to find out why other people
like us we lived in Amsterdam
as you heard from Cody for a number of
years and later we moved to Provence
near ex
four walls and we made it a ritual to go
down to some poor vivants every summer
to see the have lunch there to see the
wonderful phone Garcia mocks which has a
great art collection and to enjoy the
it's a very unique special ambiance
there and I thought it would be nice for
my next book the last one was about
Cezanne and others were about the Pope's
Jews in Provence and one was a big photo
book sort of a cocktail table size about
the cat's photograph by the world's
greatest photographers Cartier Bresson
and those kind of people so this was
sort of a challenge to say what could I
do that's different about Baldwin and I
found out that this period that he was
in samples of ants which was from 1970
to 1987 has been written about very
little everybody knows about the periods
in in New York and other places but this
one and then I thought maybe a fresh
approach might be let's find out people
who came to visit him there and how they
shaved his life they're like Carol and
Danielle and Niklas and a lot of famous
people like Sidney Poitier and Harry
Belafonte and Angela Davis and all those
people so I set off and it took me more
than four years and it might be a
reflection of my slow writing to get
this book together and I got on the
phone very brazen like and called
everybody and said perhaps you would
like to help reminisce about well
everybody to the last man was happy to
to cooperate nobody was said I'm too
busy or what
some of these people like I've met I was
able to interview a visit here in New
York people like David Lamy who
unfortunately couldn't come today
because he's now living in Connecticut
and he's travelling but David lemming
and other people like that who spent a
lot of time with Baldwin at home and
that's what we look besides those I was
also interested in the everyday contacts
he had with the people in some hold of
ants because that's not the most obvious
place for a New Yorker from Harlem to
come live it's a very all-white
conservative agrarian community that has
never seen a black man in their lives
and they thought it was kind of a
revolutionary and the police had a car
parked outside his door which everybody
said oh you're fancy song but it was
really there which came out in later
publications so he had a hard time he
said it was just like being in New York
and Harlem they do one's antagonism but
due to his broad bigtooth smile he won
over the people be everybody he walked
in the street he said hey Joe once go
back and have a drink with me or well
let's stop here and he correctly from
the Ronco because she she she knew him
very well of course so this was part of
it the walk is concerned with why did
Baldwin go to some Paul he was feeling
depressed and on the verge of a nervous
breakdown because of all the
assassinations in America because of the
resistance to his work with the as an
activist the other young black writers
were condemning him he was having
problems on all sides he felt it so he
fled to Paris again for the second time
and there he with a self induced
breakdown probably mental
he got into the American Hospital and no
Yi just outside of Paris and after
treatment they someone said why don't
you go to some Paul you know people
there for you a convalescence so he went
to some Paul and he was greeted there
and again in this hotel which became his
second home by Simone senior a and Eve
one tom
he knew Simone from the student riots in
the 60s he was there at that time and he
watched television with her and drank a
lot of booze to all hours of the night
so he had a very C Mon and he both lived
in the hotel in separate rooms so he was
in Simone's room for all these
encounters and she said you have to stay
here and I'll help and the place that
they that she came up with was a very
elegant 17th century bus seat a big big
home in virtually about one kilometer
from the heart of the city but really
very elegant and the only problem was
that the owner was someone who hated
blacks she came from Algeria where they
were dispossessed during the Algerian
war on a very rich family even though
she was only two years old and she kept
this hatred for anybody black but Simone
and the woman owner of the hotel local
owned or convinced her to do it
so what did she do she built a big brick
thing of blocking her heart doors too
hard part of the house almost well
actually she put it on a lot more there
a big you a big this wardrobe and so he
couldn't never come into her space but
slowly slowly slowly through the years
and she wanted him to have the house and
years of with a loneliness and so forth
she passed on that had men she wanted so
she he kept buying rooms in the house
but he didn't have money to pay for them
so he gave her I Oh use and on her
deathbed and some hold of aunts in the
village she had them pinned to her
nightgown same with leaving instructions
he can't get to house till he pays so
that became a court case for 20 years
between the cleaning woman who was
supposedly distant family and claimed
that she was she was entitled as the
closest to habit and all these remote
relatives who appeared from nowhere so
for 20 years the house stood empty it
was a pilloried by people who sold
shutters off the building it was rain
coming in but nobody on until it was
finally settled and this cleaning woman
got the house finally and sold it and
now there is in the news again because
the present owner wants and build 20
villas on this beautiful property in the
monuments committee didn't do anything
to protect it and he's already knocked
down two wings of the house and no one
knows what's gonna happen but that's in
the news now
one of the things in in this the book
explores life with Jimmy and with over
70 interviewers and as I said it took me
four years before you because
the essence of the book is to try to get
to know his life to the people who came
there and besides the famous people like
Maya Angelou and those people there were
everyday people everyday locals who were
very close to him his doctor after
retired it wasn't there from every night
for dinner his mailman who was a very
young boy at the time used to come
because he was the only one in sample
who read any English and he had to take
down the telegrams which which came in
by Morse code or something word by word
by word and then bring it and he said he
told me he said I came then I was 15 or
16 and he would always greet me with a
big kiss
he said I'm lucky but he was like a
grandmother to me that hit me he was at
work and I always got invited in for a
drink
and and he was living in this tense
situation at that moment with being
followed even in America when he went
back to teach and so he went to New York
the FBI was on his tail everybody was
saying this is only well and he called
him a black homosexual communist and he
has to be he has to be followed it was
not a communist and I think Jo Vancouver
should have come out of the closet
[Laughter]
people like
Rolling Stones guitarist Bill Wyman was
a good friend of his and there's a
picture of them together in the book the
book has fifty photos which trace his
earliest days there with Carol Danielle
and and other people see Monsignor a and
so go right up to his burial here in New
York and son Sean Devine that the
Cathedral I think well taking distance
from America he retained a love-hate
relationship he always felt very
American he said I can't be an
expatriate that's only only for white
people because I have a lot of baggage
with me with my family history and the
heritage and don't forget I was as a
grandson of a slave and so he always
felt this this double-sided relationship
and he finally became as he called
himself he's always said I'm a small
ugly gay black American as he likes to
describe himself but he was far lated he
accepted as one of us in the community
and one of the wonderful things just
going back to the picture for one minute
is I asked the waiter in the hotel why
is there a photo of James Baldwin here I
understand Picasso because he came and
all the others and he said because he
was like a son to the family rule ro u X
who owned the hotel and the grandmother
of the present generation said we want
you to be part of the family and you
come eat with us and you stay with us
and so forth even though he had his own
home and this went on with her daughter
and with the present generation they saw
him as a sibling as a brother and a
phone
and they supported him and of course
with Simone's backing and the family
rule which are the most important in
town because of their establishment
helped him become known and accepted by
the people he remained a displaced
American writer using black English
which Toni Morrison confirmed in one of
her writings that she learned a lot of
that from him that he didn't and he
never wrote anything he never wrote
anything that gave gave indication that
he was living in France it was always as
if he was in where he was in America and
doing his usual essays and writing and
so forth and the only thing he was
writing when he died was called the
Welcome Table because he he called the
dining room outdoor and indoor the
welcome table and people who came
he had guests day and night and he
didn't have the money for it he was
getting huge advances from the
publishers and it was spent before the
check was cashed practically and this
went on and on long until it really
became a problem after his death with
money that he had gotten from a major
publisher and of course it couldn't be
bad be paid back but he was writing this
book this play the Welcome Table said
anything but he died before it was
finished but aside from that everything
he ever did was America American
oriented I think I hope that answers the
question why I did it I was fascinated
by Baldwin being in this little French
village by the people who came everybody
I found all kinds of people one of his
lovers that fled to the Caribbean after
he well died because of the relationship
all kinds of people local the mailman
the chauffeurs the cafe owners everybody
came and everybody I did not find
anybody who had a disparaging word about
him he was very popular they were very
successful and I think it's wonderful
that such a book could be produced with
only the good evidence and all the nice
people on the panel Nikolas lives nearby
as you heard who was there all the time
I remember from his book that his wife
was keeping notes about when they were
there and there was a little lunch and
dinner or dinner and lunch or breakfast
and dinner and so almost he had to have
a lot of people around him all the time
for people he likes he was very close to
the artistic community in some Paul the
artists who painted and to the writers
that were there Nicholas and a few hours
and I think that more or less tells the
story of the Vulcan I hope you enjoy it
thank you very much in her words her
relationship with Jimmy and through her
partner David and her frequent and early
visits staying in the house being with
him here in the writing that he read to
her and to several other people I had
the breakfast as a lunch table because
he got up very late he works all night
drank a lot of whiskey and then produced
this fiction or essays and then he we
asked several very close friends and his
secretary and his family to please tell
me what do you think so please Carol
maybe thank you very much Jules
I met David Baldwin in 1964 in the East
Village at a party I was living in the
area and we met at a party at the home
of an attorney that worked for Jimmy and
then it was up or down from there to be
literally the next three quarters of my
life in terms of amazing experiences and
things that I treasure so David was at
that time in rehearsal for a blues for
mr. Charlie which I know anybody in the
audience see it well a lot of people
left because they couldn't handle it it
was quite a play actually a wonderful
work of Jimmy's that has never received
the proper do as much of his work but I
was at every performance at the answer
theater every night and then it closed
and it went to London for a little while
and then it ended and there have been
resurgence 'as of the play in fact it
was done recently my dad Daniel lives in
Providence Rhode Island at the Trinity
Repertory Theatre which was exciting to
see after all these years it's a
wonderful day to read it's an important
play and so many people said it was
polemic and didn't want to have to face
what was the play about which it was
based on the amateur lynchings and other
lynchings and so it's interesting to
note that given this was early way back
in 1964 and he had quite a hard time
with the after studio and Lee Strasberg
and the whole clan to get it done and
burgess Meredith was involved in the
whole process as well as a lot of great
actors including the
sentence and many others so I then went
with David 1967 to Istanbul and we lived
in the house Jimmy was exiting that
summer and that's why I submit David
rooming who has written the biography
about Jimmy and I've known David that
long and then we closed the house we
went to London we got an apartment for
Jimmy and his sister Poehler and David
and I we lived in runs together in 1967
the fall of 67 through the spring of 68
then I came back to New York and in 1971
I went back over to Amsterdam to live so
when I saw that she did this wonderful
book I got a copy of it and it is a
wonderful book great photographs and
apparently he was living there with
Barbara in those years and I just found
that out which is really cool so I
definitely loved Amsterdam and while we
live there Jimmy bought the house
actually end of 70 we went on in the
fall of 71 when I was supposed to be
working at a medical publishing house
but I snuck away and we I got an old
Volkswagen and we drove through the
mountains and fought all the way about
how to shift and not shift and I was I
was a great driver I'd been a cab driver
by the way so I know how to drive but I
didn't know how to drive a stick until I
moved to Europe so we got to Jimmy's at
6:00 in the morning and Jimmy opened the
door and he had all this food made for
us all kinds of classic slow food
he loved to cook didn't do it often but
he loved to cook and he was delighted
that we came to welcome the house with
him we stayed for about a week and then
we drove back to him and then I went to
the house 72 73 74
and then he was born in 73 and he came
in seventy five six nine and at least
four more years a couple of times and
some of these pictures here that you see
these are my photos except for one and
they followed them were in the book that
I let Jules put in the book and of
course they're not really good I was not
a photographer I was not trying to do
that I was taking it for his memory book
we didn't ever think of Jimmy as famous
Jimmy Jimmy was Jimmy Uncle Jimmy and my
friends at me my brother of Jimmy so I
had the fortune good fortune incredible
fortune to get to know Jimmy very well
as a human being you know who was Jimmy
as a man as a kind human being
to the world and so opposite what the
images people try to perpetuate about
him so I got to not only admire him but
to see him as an advisor to me like when
I made decisions about which I'd send
Daniel to school he would weigh in on
that what did he think about the
infamous teacher strike that I didn't
strike in during 1968 when I started my
high school teaching career and what did
he think about that so what's
fascinating is a lot of what's going on
right now is exactly what was going on
in and that's pretty terrifying so if
anything we need Jimmy more than we ever
ever ever did so Daniel would go with me
in the summers we would stay all summer
because I was teaching so I had the
summer free and we had the most
extraordinary times he treated Daniel
very much it was his brother's son and
loved him as well he couldn't love him
more he would just get a thrill so maybe
I'll turn this over to my son
and if he wants to read this already I
think you should read it this is
something Jimmy wrote about Daniel which
David let me give me a copy of very late
in the day but I think it's pretty
special all right just as a bit of an
introduction obviously because we all
know who I am I'm Daniel Baldwin James
Baldwin was my uncle and actually to say
it just as a bit of an opening I always
considered myself lucky just especially
looking back on it I was lucky because I
was a black kid New York City didn't
have a lot of money and got to go spend
the summers in France like how cool is
that right like you don't know it's
cooler than your - and you're almost
drowning in front of Moreau ended up
with a queue aquaphobia for the next
three years I can take a shower or
anything but you know you look back on
it as you get older and people are
always asking what was it like what was
it like what was it like it was like
having a family most of us grew up with
the family might had an alcohol my dad
not they've got that really cool uncle
okay my uncle Jimmy was my really cool
uncle that's all it was he was just the
cooler on Glee at the cool house in
France it was warm there were pear trees
in his yard I mean the guy pears just
what the supermarket it was a better one
great awesome there cats running all
over the place to me which is like Oh
heaven you know you're especially a
little kid but even as you get only 18
years you don't realise what's in front
of you when it's there
it hasn't use you get older growing up
black Jewish in America take your pick
and I've looked all over the country and
nobody ever gets it right I must beat a
podium
they must be Algerian unless the Middle
Eastern and must be an American kinda
pens my outfit for the day put on the
way costume but my uncle had a lot to do
with me understand my identity growing
up in the sense of be willing to go
that's my mom that's my bad
I'm walking up between that's great and
it was really made a lot easier to
accept Who I was growing up not to be
confused about it
which good happy now you can see when
you go left Center trying to figure out
who I so this is weird for me a group of
people at least not with watching a few
videos intercepted memo classified as
follows in part it will be remembered
than the poem Bonaparte of attraction
I'm sorry attraction Corsica a province
of France is the last general and
Emperor of the French might have had far
more trouble than we have had with this
somewhat unpredictable island it has
come to attention that a certain Daniel
of the Dutch English now American
province of Harlem is now in the South
of France he counts in at least two
languages and he speaks in one there's a
first thing that work around the clock
deciphering the code is cover as
Americans we put it
traveling with his mother we have our
budget experts at work on this aspect of
the problem this daniel has been seen
lately in Monte Carlo where he exhibited
a distinctively suspicious friendship
with the fish in the aquarium who also
seemed to respond
I need not I need not detail do you how
delicate this is in view of our recent
ongoing counterintelligence permits with
marine life he is also familiarize
himself with the casino and it is
suspected that the vulnerable Princess
Grace has whipped on him to favor he
also spoke at length with a group of
Arabs unluckily we have not yet decipher
this code either this night July 19 1975
he was seeing the Cologne door where he
one conversed with parrots to guide
Augusta to and around the pool three mr.
square by his members LTTE members are
Levon it was observed that the bartender
Pierrot smuggles and peanuts and
crackers he was also seeing with two
straws seven he has received yes
exceeding one enormous volleyball
several cars one elephant several other
cattle and a fleet of cars eight he had
enough candy to offer at handy to almost
everyone on the terrace nine he taught
him English couple how to roll the dice
and he will see with members well see
someone seen array in the television
room couple invited him back twelve the
parents invited him back
thirteen he spends a great deal of time
with his uncle's Arab gardener fourteen
he appears to speak a kind of Creole
with his uncle's made Valerie she was
the only person in the house understood
me for three years and this clearly is
just the beginning we had enough trouble
of a poem as you must remember if we do
not move quickly we may find ourselves
crushed between the jealous Corsicans
and the intrepid Daniel and then what
will become a France believe me sir your
most devoted and obedient etc etc
[Applause]
well it's hard to follow I've been
struck all evening by the presence of
the past how vividly he occupies this
room again and how welcome we all we're
at that table at first and last saw
Daniel when he was the size of his shoe
so I'm gonna follow
Jimmy's lead and because I am a writer
and the definition of a writer is that
we take more care with the language that
we put on a page than that which rolls
grandiloquent ly off our tongues I
thought I would read to you from the
book to which Jules kindly referred and
which he quotes in the Welcome Table
this book of mine that came out almost
30 years ago about our shared
neighborhood it's called running in
place scenes from the South of France
my wife and I in fact were in the South
of France this very week and returned
from it having given shut enough I mean
sampled of AUSA a wide berth because the
house and its history is no longer a
happy one but my memories of it are
almost wholly happy and I thought I'd
share a few pages from this book about
that I first met Jimmy in
consequentially as it were in in
Istanbul in 1970 Flair of his was
running I didn't speak any Turkish we
sort of grinned at each other and shook
hands once or twice but then we ran into
him as he was moving in
- this must eat and this was just as we
were planning to leave
we had about a week I was I think
shocked by how warm and immediate his
welcome was in that week we probably
drank all 40 bottles had 30 meals
couldn't get out of town or country
without his blessing and it felt like a
literally fast friendship formed but
what I want to reach you about is a
period in 1974 when we returned Jimmy
Baldwin however remained this time he
welcomed us like long-lost friends he
established a work pattern and an
entourage
he had a chauffeur large enough to
double as a bodyguard a cook a companion
named Philippe who acted as a kind of
secretary manager and various others
whose function is less easy to describe
there would be a dancer or painter in
tow old lovers or associates from some
project in the offing
or projected or long past they came from
Italy America Algeria Tunisia Finland
brothers and nephews passed through we
were rarely less than six a table and
more often ten the cook and the
fundament eyes came and went the men
stayed on they treated their provider
with a fond deference as if his talent
must be sheltered from invasive detail
the rude importunate matters of fact
they answered the phone on the door they
sorted mail there was an intricate
hierarchy of rank a jockeying for
position that evokes nothing so much as
a province our court who's in favour who
out who had known Jimmy longer were
better aware who would do the shopping
or join him in Paris for the television
interview or hell
with a book jacket photo he was working
again on a novel
if Beale Street could talk Jimmy drank
scotch we drank wine I've not as yet
described the quality of kindness in his
manner the affection he expected and
expressed his face is widely known that
dark glare broad nose those large
protruding eyes the close-fitting cap of
curls then starting to go white but
photographs cannot convey the mobileplat
of feature the intensity of utterance
the sense he could contrive to give the
attention matters and gesture can count
there was something theatrical in
Baldwin's manner and it grew automatic
at times he would embark on what seemed
to Terada high-speed compilation of
phrases that clearly had been phrased
before a kind of improvised lecture spun
out of previous speech he stared at you
unblinkingly you couldn't turn away he
wore expensive jewelry and fingered it
talking he smoked he'd been holding
center stage for years you've shifted in
your seat you said yes but and he raised
his imperious manicure at hand dialogue
for Baldwin was an interrupted monologue
he would yield the platform neither
willing they know along he could speak
incisively on a book he hadn't read
but again and again he impressed me with
his canny raging ranging his alert
intelligence understand me he'd say it's
important that you understand and it was
important and you understood my pleasure
in our meetings is easily explained here
was the spokesman of his generation and
color speaking directly to me that he
took my opinions seriously that he read
and respected my work or appeared to
that he wanted us with him as often as
possible
all this was flattering when we parted
late at night Jimmy would say see you
two tomorrow if we came for lunch
instead he urged us to stay on for
dinner when a friend passed through San
Paul he would insist we meet well he
wanted to be with us is I think less
clear each friendship partakes of the
reciprocal trade agreement and I can
only speculate as to Baldwin's motives
in the trade he was the most sociable of
solitaries but constantly attended and
attended to he seemed nonetheless alone
he wanted to hear news from home Elena
my wife had worked several years in a
rehabilitation agency for drug addicts
in New York whose clientele was largely
black she moved easily through his own
streets though she was without exception
the single woman in his house and in a
party of a dozen men she was given pride
of place she sat at his right hand they
liked each other I believe with
unfettered immediate liking she treated
him with just the right mixture of
impatience and respect they embraced
each other meaning it they huddled in
corners together
there was nothing exclusionary about his
attitude to women though surrounded by
adoring boys he was also a family man I
mattered to him I suppose as a
practitioner of a shared trade he told
me he was starved for the chance to talk
books for a discussion say of Henry
James with someone who would read
we talked the way most writers do in a
kind of shorthand and sign language we
asked each other always either work at
gone that day how this paragraph was
doing with that character and scene this
is a lengthy recollection and I'm gonna
skip to his end we'd been at his house
in Semple DeVos two or three times in a
row it was our turn therefore to invite
the Baldwin clan we did so one Thursday
for lunch
they said they would come happily there
were seven maybe nine the two members of
his party I remember his men passing
through we're a dancer called Bertha and
a publisher named Willie the former was
lean live beautiful and black he danced
at the forty Berea the latter was
mountainous white we'd been warned about
his appetite by Baldwin's cooked days
before Willie was a voracious eater
who'd sent her to the market three times
at that afternoon in the gatehouse the
very small gardener's cottage in effect
of a very grand estate switchbacks and
you know etc this was owned by an
elderly woman who was nothing if not
snobbish and whom I hear referred to as
a little Rosenthal okay
Elena planted never right we made an
extra pot but never those simple takes
time to prepare we started the previous
day we cubed the lamb and browned it in
fashion the bouquet garni we peeled
turnips and carrots and leeks the low
rosenthal knocked
she was hoping we might join her
tomorrow for lunch
there were people she thought we should
meet we made our excuses invited her in
as she could see we too were preparing a
male meal we would therefore be unable
to join or invite her for we owed a
friend
thank you never huh I remember not
naming his name part of this was inverse
snobbery just a distaste for glitter by
association and part the suspicion that
had lilo known baldwin was coming we
should have had to invite her also they
would have been water and oil but anyway
she told us she hoped we were taking our
wash it hadn't on the clothes line
outside she wanted to walk by the house
and let her friends take photographs
they were passionate photographers her
friends were distinguished she said they
were the last of the Hapsburgs
and the last of the Hohenzollerns
respectively for perhaps they were the
last of the Schlitz figs and Holsteins
are collateral branches instead in any
case they were old and distinguished and
wouldn't appreciate the laundry on our
line she hoped we would ready the house
we promised we made ii never brought an
extra dozen bottles from the CAF brought
three additional bull from the baker and
waited for Jimmy to come himself he had
however purchased a brand new Mercedes
dark brown and substantial just short of
stretch limousine size his
his driver his driver would be working
that day he had assured me they had no
need of our little tattered car he was
bringing back our novel
Phillip Billy Willie and burn are at the
appointed hour we were ready a car came
the day was overcast what pulled into
the parking space behind lecomba
Sal was not to Jimmy's Mercedes but in
ancient gray Renault it was followed
fini really by adieu cheveux Lila
Rosenthal appeared her guests emerged
they were slow and small and bent the
process of arrival took some time the
doors opened faltered closed the last of
the hapsburgs in the last of the horn
Solon's wore dark suits and carried
cameras and advanced with umbrellas and
canes they shuffled off together to
their villa they kissed one another's
hands as soon as they were out of sight
we heard another car the deep throated
growl of gears the high hum of power and
harness the trumpeting bravura of the
horn and Baldwin's Mercedes Reuter its
spat and raked gravel it rocked on its
brakes is fairly pirouetted in the
sudden Sun four doors flung wide and
unison our company had come they were
dressed for the occasion
grandly there were boaters and fool of
their boots gleamed Bert car especially
was splendid he emerged twirling his
scarf and waist sash a pink silk he did
a few dance steps and flung his hat high
and extended his hands for applause we
applauded Jimmy embraced us we him the
chauffeur was not happy with the
switchbacks of the entry drive there
badly backed he said he brought his
lunch along and elected to stay with the
car he stood arms folded glowering down
through the olive groves
he was Danish thick and solid and
pervious to charm what a charming place
we piloted them in this wasn't easy they
swarmed they raced to the crest of the
meadow and watched tiptoe along the rim
of the best sir they approved the view
they clattered through our little house
exclaiming at the style of it posing on
the bedroom balcony
let's have la vie Oh those Phillipe had
brought flowers
he garland it Elena Dara Jimmy Willie
and Beth car we emptied four bottles of
wine by the time we settled to eat the
never van was a success the publisher
Willie approved audibly
he sighed he sat back and rolled up his
sleeves which pots for me he asked they
were olives in Pat's a there was much
laughter celebration praise for the
cellars and bread the dining room could
barely contain us we rolled about the
table like a litter of puppies suckling
jostling slicing sausages and cheese and
fruit and cake a shadow appeared at the
window
I looked up Lila Rosenthal was outside
she and her four companions were inching
to the house they had their cameras at
shoulder level focusing and it painted
them clearly to approach we must have
looked to them like Spengler's nightmare
realized the decline of the West the
beaming black man at the center the live
array around him the voluminous white
man with loaves in his hands the young
hosts plying everyone with wine the
pyramid of bottles the ruckus of
festivity the Mercedes being polished
all this was hard to focus on or frame I
could see lilo explaining I do not know
she explained there was no laundry
however
they circled warily we didn't invite
them in they moved to the back of the
house niklas that was wonderful thank
you very much part of this is excerpt in
the book his permission because I found
it so tell it's so important are there
any questions now for the people of the
panel or my mayor you have to leave it
okay my idea
oh well questions from the public to
anybody on the panel or to me thank you
all for coming and for having patients
and we all appreciated the family there
are the literary friends and the publish
the book they book culture token Cody
who did such a good job in organizing
this thank you very much so we're gonna
real quick set Jules up front to sign
copies for anybody who wants into
celebrating this part of James Baldwin's
legacy